3...2...1.
Narrator: TORY, GRANT,
AND KARI HAVE FOUND THAT
TRYING TO CLOUT YOUR WAY OUT
OF A CASKET "KILL BILL" STYLE
AIN'T ALL IT'S CRACKED UP TO BE.
BUT AS A POTENTIAL FINAL NAIL
IN THIS MYTH'S COFFIN,
THERE'S ONE LAST PART TO TEST.
NOW, WE'VE BUSTED
THE PART OF THE MYTH
WHERE YOU CAN PUNCH THROUGH
A CASKET.
BUT NOW WE'RE GONNA
TEST THE PART OF THE MYTH
THAT IF YOU DID
BUST THROUGH THE CASKET,
COULD YOU DIG
THROUGH SIX FEET OF DIRT?
SO WHAT I NEED TO DO IS, I NEED
TO RECONFIGURE THIS RIG HERE
SO THAT WE CAN GET INSIDE OF IT
AND SAFELY
TRY TO DIG OUR WAY OUT.
Narrator: NOW, IF THE MOVIE
HEROINE WAS SUPERHUMAN
OR THE COFFIN LID
RIDDLED WITH WOODWORM,
MAYBE SHE COULD HAVE
PUNCHED THROUGH.
AND IF SO,
COULD SHE THEN HAVE ESCAPED?
TO FIND OUT,
TORY REPLACES THE CASKET LID
WITH A SLIDING HATCH
TO HOLD BACK THE DIRT ABOVE.
ALL RIGHT,
SO THIS IS THE TRAPDOOR.
IT'S GONNA OPEN LIKE THAT,
AND THEN WE'LL START
DIGGING OUR WAY OUT.
Narrator: HE'S ALSO BUILT
AN ACRYLIC CASKET,
WITH A SPECIALLY DESIGNED
ESCAPE HATCH
THAT'S ALL READY
FOR A TRIAL RUN.
SO, THE NEW CASKET'S IN PLACE,
AND WHAT I'M GONNA DO RIGHT NOW
IS JUST TEST THE TRAPDOOR
AND SEE IF IT'S WORKING.
OHH!
IT WORKS.
AND I'M OUT SAFELY.
Narrator:
WELL...SORT OF SAFELY.
AAH.
BETTER THAN...DYING.
Narrator: MEANWHILE,
GRANT'S GOT THE DIRT ON DIRT.
SO DIRT WEIGHS BETWEEN
65 AND 88 POUNDS PER CUBIC FOOT,
AND WE KNOW FROM OUR
"BURIED IN THE SAND" EXPERIMENT
THAT THOSE TYPES OF PRESSURES
ON YOUR CHEST CAVITY
CAN GET VERY DANGEROUS
VERY QUICK.
NOW, TRADITIONALLY, CASKETS ARE
BURIED SIX FEET UNDER DIRT.
BUT, FOR SAFETY, WE'RE GONNA
START OUT WITH JUST TWO FEET.
Narrator:
BUT EVEN ONLY TWO FEET UNDER,
KARI, FOR ONE, IS SURE
TORY'S DIGGING HIS OWN GRAVE.
I HAVE A FEELING
THE COFFIN'S GONNA FILL UP
AND PIN HIM BEFORE HE'S ABLE TO
DIG HIS WAY OUT.
Narrator: SO, PEPPED UP
BY KARI'S CONFIDENCE,
TORY PUTS ON
AN ANTI-CRUSH SUIT...
THIS OUGHT TO STOP THE DIRT
FROM COMPRESSING MY LUNGS.
Narrator:
...AND MOST IMPORTANT,
A FIRE-BRIGADE
BREATHING APPARATUS.
ONE PANICKED LOOK LATER,
AND IT'S "GO" TIME.
BE CAREFUL IN THERE.
Narrator: TORY CAREFULLY
SLIDES HIS WAY INTO THE COFFIN
AS HE PREPARES TO LITERALLY
PUT HIS LIFE ON THE LINE.
YOU READY?
I'M READY.
ALL RIGHT, I'M GONNA
OPEN THE DOOR SLOWLY.
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THIS SEEMS LIKE A HORRIBLE IDEA.
Narrator:
TORY'S BURIAL RITUAL BEGINS.
KARI RELEASES THE TRAPDOOR,
EXACTLY AS IF HE'D BEEN ABLE TO
PUNCH A HOLE IN THAT COFFIN LID.
THE TRICKLE OF DIRT
BEGINS TO FALL IN ON HIM.
OH, THIS IS FREAKY.
OKAY, KEEP GOING.
YEAH, KEEP GOING.
Narrator:
KARI OPENS IT WIDER,
AND IT RAPIDLY
BECOMES AN AVALANCHE,
AND IT'S PANIC STATIONS BELOW.
[BLEEP]
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
STOP! STOP!
I'M ALL RIGHT.
I'M OKAY, I'M OKAY.
Narrator: THE TWO FEET OF DIRT
HAS CAVED IN ON HIM,
BUT THERE'S A BONUS.
IT'S OPENED UP
A RABBIT HOLE ABOVE.
DAYLIGHT! WHOO!
Narrator:
BUT STILL TRAPPED,
HE PUSHES THE DIRT
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE COFFIN,
WRIGGLES, AND THEN
SCRAPES HIS WAY UPRIGHT,
AND WITH A MASSIVE EFFORT,
ACTUALLY TRIUMPHS
IN TUNNELING HIS WAY OUT.
AHH!
I'M ALIVE!
Narrator: TORY'S PROVED
THAT AT TWO FEET UNDER,
ASSUMING YOU COULD
OPEN THE COFFIN LID,
ESCAPE IS JUST CONCEIVABLE.
BUT THE MYTH CALLS FOR
A NORMAL BURIAL.
NOW, OUR NEXT SETUP IS GONNA BE
UNDER THE FULL SIX FEET OF DIRT.
Narrator:
YEP, YOU HEARD RIGHT, FOLKS --
GRANT IS GOING TO BE BURIED
A FULL SIX FEET UNDER.
BUT, SO HE DOESN'T DIE,
HIS PLAN IS TO SIT UP,
NOT LIE DOWN, IN THE COFFIN.
OKAY, LET'S PAUSE
FOR KARI'S PREDICTION.
AT FOUR FEET,
IT'S ALL GONNA COLLAPSE DOWN
AND COMPLETELY GO PEAR-SHAPED.
OKAY, KARI,
GO AHEAD.
Narrator: KARI AT LAST
"DISHES THE DIRT" ON GRANT.
KEEP GOING.
Narrator: THOUSANDS OF POUNDS
OF SOIL SLITHER SOUTH.
OKAY, STOP! STOP!
Narrator:
...AND ALMOST IMMEDIATELY,
GRANT'S BURIED TO THE NECK,
UNABLE TO MOVE,
AT LEAST UNTIL THE RIG BREAKS
UNDER THE PRESSURE.
IT'S EASY TO SEE THAT
IF GRANT HAD BEEN LYING DOWN,
HE'D BE DEAD.
WELL, I GUESS
THAT WORKED WELL.
YEAH, I THINK
THAT PRETTY MUCH SUMS IT UP.
Narrator:
THE AIR TUNNEL THAT TORY USED
NEVER OPENED UP FOR GRANT,
AND THAT MEANT
ESCAPE WAS TOTALLY IMPOSSIBLE.